your enemies over the past several
months we've had these rather bizarre
expose is about spies and the defector
from the Soviet Union who read affected
in all that seems so rather really
strange what do you make of this
the Soviet agent who read affected in
all can you all the sense of it for the
broader subject is and and mind you I've
gotten many phone calls people
journalists TV people asking for my
assessment and the question is why are
we having so many spies and we're we
having in 1985 a dozen or so that we
catch you know why is our nation
suddenly going bad why are people all of
a sudden spying and this question was so
superficial I couldn't believe some of
the people who were asking it we're
asking him because the spies didn't
begin spying in 1985 they were just all
arrested in 1985 the the one the red
Chinese spy had been reporting for for
thirty years another family had been
working for for eighteen years and
others for varying periods of time the
fact that they're all arrested in one
period of time means nothing more than
the fact that they were arrested in one
period of time this means that the
policy of the US government towards
arresting people suspected of espionage
had changed and become much more
aggressive and that gets back to the
arguments of Jim angleton the the
notoriously paranoid counterintelligence
chief of the CIA now retired who
believed that the agency was riddled
with this with spies and he couldn't get
approval authority to arrest them and go
after them allegedly he had a team of
assassins and they would do Viktor
marchetti's book and Viktor marchetti's
lectures addressed this and he worked in
the same office he said that England
wanted to go and hit the CIA people
suspected of being double agents well
what Marchetti said they did in fact
since the policy then was to spare the
US government of the embarrassment of
finding spy
in its own ranks to make us look
ideologically pure and the Soviet Union
would be riddled with spies and
defectors and so the policy then was not
to prosecute unless you absolutely had
to and they're relatively few
prosecutions occur according to
Marchetti and he didn't have too much
credibility when he was first bringing
out this thesis in the mid 70s now he
looks much better was that when they
would find a spy back then they would do
one of two things that they had an
office they would kill them or which
would be done as he put it moat only in
the more you know the more dangerous the
more dramatic cases in the other cases
they would go to them and say we know
what you've been up to we think you
should retire and go and live in Florida
and if you ever breathe a word to anyone
of what you've done then we will
prosecute and then according to
Marchetti there was another out that
they had which would be to shoot someone
up with with drug blow their mind with
drugs and then you know they are clearly
mentally unbalanced and then the CI
steps into the family and says you know
we're very sorry this patriotic citizen
you know his work colleague has worked
with us your father your husband has had
this breakdown we will put them in this
to protect the secrets that he might
reveal we'll put them in a special nice
sanatorium and we'll foot the bill for
the rest of his life and you can go and
visit him on Sundays and so the family
feels grateful and they can go and visit
their loved one on Sundays and he's kept
shot up with drugs until his mind is
completely blown and it can be of no you
know in fact it's crazy and has it can
be a no threat to anyone this is what
Marchetti was saying was being done and
and as being the explanation of why we
had so few prosecutions over the years
in 1985 they clearly a new Justice
Department they've clearly decided that
that they looked sent it so cynical
already that they might as well get a
plus from it instead of - they began
prosecuting spies and going after them
one after the other vigorously on
getting as much publicity from it as
they could
John on one hand obviously the regular
administration has decided to
aggressively go after these spires been
another hand they must have some way of
getting them are there new techniques
what are some of the methods they're
using is there increased surveillance
electronic gadgetry that's helping catch
them or what well according to the
Marchetti thesis there are no new
techniques they were catching them all
along they just weren't prosecuting very
many of them very dramatically it could
very well be that they have in fact they
do have more sophisticated electronic
techniques now than they had 10 years
ago and 20 years ago and 30 years ago my
guess is that my own sense of the thing
is that the mark Marchetti thesis is
probably the explanation they were
finding these people before and just not
going after them
this was our understanding when I was in
the agency we talked about this a lot
and this was our understanding was that
they just the place had to be riddled
with spies but they were just not
prosecuting them well what pardon lie
detectors playing this well the CIA
people had to take a lie detector test
once a years I didn't when when we went
in we all took a lie detector and then
they told us we would be boxed as we
called it once a year in fact nobody was
boxed I never except if they were a
subject of some specific investigation I
say and once in a while very really you
would see two or three people in your
area division would be called in to be
boxed and this of course would cause a
lot of gossip and feelings and of course
you never knew whether they themselves
were being investigated or whether in
fact they were they were dummies you
know somebody else is being investigated
so you do three people over here so it
won't single out the one person that
you're really interested in so this is
different there are more aggressively
using these lie detector now apparently
you are and of course the lie detector
machine is virtually worthless in terms
of fighting out you know is is someone
line but it does have one psychological
the reason they cling to it because
they're not foolish they wouldn't waste
all that resource if it was totally
ineffectual its effect isn't scaring
people this is one of the few things
I've seen President Reagan say that I
the other day he said he said that
forces people to confess and it is true
that there are a lot of people who when
they're faced with the fact that they're
going to be boxed well kind of have a
mini nervous breakdown and say oh yes I
as a matter of fact I wanted to tell you
something I start to cut a deal and
start to cut a deal or start to explain
or say something which will lead to
other things it won't get anyone who has
any kind of strength of their
convictions and refuses to cooperate
it'll show that they're nervous it'll
show that they had too much coffee or
maybe not anything at all the way the
way the Soviets for example teach their
operate is that they're sending against
us to beat the lie-detector test is
they'll practice and they you know they
have training classes until they really
get it down of thinking of something
stressful or pinching themselves hurting
themselves at Agra for four questions on
which they're telling the truth and and
then that'll create the reaction on the
machine and then when you ask them a
question in which they have to lie it'll
create the same reaction more or less
and the operator can't you know he can't
judge whether or not you're lying he can
only say the machine shows some stress
at every third question and it's a
simple technique and it works with
practice with certain type of people
let's ask the question about the
Yurchenko affair that would seem very
strange from two aspects first of all
that he just wandered off and went home
so easily and secondly that supposedly
he was the one who was fingering a lot
of some of these spies that were later
prosecuted and according to the
government there are a lot of other
prosecutions coming up because of the
information you're chenko gave them this
sounds so bizarre because he returned to
the Soviet
yeah that's that's happening yeah yeah
in in my assessment and needless to say
that's another one been called about
many times in my assessment he had to
have been sent over by the Soviets I
believe if you go back and read the ones
that they claimed were fingered by
Yurchenko you don't find any important
ones and and one of them that was
fingered conveniently escaped the
country before the FBI could pick him up
the first point she brought out is not
strange of how could he wander off you
know by now after four or five decades
of dealing with a communist Soviet Union
we've had dozens of thousands of
defectors occasionally dramatic ones get
high publicity but the United States
government has no intention of getting
in the position of financing for the
rest of their lives at thirty five or
forty thousand dollars a year every
Russian who wants to come and live in
the United States I mean you're talking
about you know altogether you can fit
all the people looking across the wall
in Berlin and everything you're talking
about maybe 50,000 people at $35,000 a
year you know forget it the policy is
what you want to do is debrief them of
anything they may know and certainly
Yurchenko if he had been legitimate
would have known a great deal the number
five men in the KGB debrief them of
anything you can get from them and then
eventually get them out in society where
they're earning their living whether
they're being Americans they want to
come to America your objective is to
make them into Americans where they earn
their own living you don't want a lot of
wards of the government hanging around
as they add up over the years in
addition to which they turn out and
evitable e2b nightmarish handling
problems it's it's every interest is to
make them feel at home
settled and eventually get them jobs so
they have their own apartment in their
own social life and their own jobs and
they make their own way so his you know
it's he was not in prison he was not
locked up you don't lock these people up
except in
and rare circumstances to the country
you're taking them to dinner in a town
and you're working towards it eventually
when they'll have their own apartment
and house and car and their own lives
all together
go ahead men here that long handle it
had been what five months so that long
okay yeah he came out in the summer and
in herds yeah except all five months I
believe at several months and he was
having dinner downtown he was apparently
cooperating fully there was no
indication that no reason for them to
have him under lock and key and they had
in fact kept no Shenko another defector
back at the time right after the Kennedy
assassination they had kept him in a
safe house locked up in prison in effect
sort of a special prison arrangement for
three years and they were heavily
criticized for this eventually
eventually they did get him in a let him
out and got him a job and and and had
sort of supported him but but but he has
established his own life this guy they
were handling in the more routine way
and he walked away when when the CI guy
who was having dinner with him went to
make a phone call
your chenko walked outside which he was
perfectly free to do and went down the
street and into the embassy wouldn't
that seem rather strange though that he
could face severe reprisal may be
execution-style in operation nor do I
believe his claim that he was kidnapped
and drugged that that just doesn't it
doesn't wash as I read the thing there
is a formality that they go through they
have to brief the Senate the Senate
committee has to meet and agree to
accept a defector that CIA case officer
out there in Rome that station chief
does not have authority to accept
responsibility for a defector he does
not have legal authority to give him a
visa much less a passport to bring him
into the United States that has to be
approved by the congressional committee
which apparently was done in this case
the Congress was not outraged that they
had been used in that
the fact that he walked into the Soviet
embassy and the next day had a press
conference went to the State Department
with his buddies from the embassy with
him and then flew away to me is a strong
indication that it was planned ahead of
time for the reason that the Soviets in
the KGB in a foreign service are
notoriously very very cautious about
reacting to dramatic situations they do
not jump until they have a reading from
Moscow on which direction to jump if if
they jump to support the guy and wave
and smile and walk with him to the State
Department and cheer and applaud what
he's done in his story and then it's
decided two days later back in Moscow
that he's a jerk and should be put away
they've done themselves you know a bad
turn the fact that they were so
obviously enthusiastic about what he'd
done and working with him indicated to
me that it was the culmination of a very
successful operation which they were
very proud of and they knew which way to
jump they knew what to do when he walked
into the embassy
what would you speculate actually
happened then from that the Soviets
wanted him to come over and pretend to
defect and then feed bad information to
the CIA defect the bad information the
theory would not completely work because
when he goes back the CIA would have to
know I mean no Shenko stayed now the
argument with no Shenko is he was sent
over to tell the United States that the
Soviet Union had not sent Lee Harvey
Oswald to kill JFK and and the theory
there is that the Soviets sent him to
defect to get this message to us and in
fact sacrificed him and a lot of
information he would give us about other
subjects just to make sure we wouldn't
go to war for him or try to kill their
leaders this guy he comes out and a few
months later goes back then everything
he said a suspect and has to be
reanalyzed and put in great doubt
so it wouldn't be a very effective way
to send forth signals or information to
the CIA so it would look more like a
game or an attempt to embarrass the CIA
to make a boy yeah a ploy the Soviet
Union at a time when it it needs a more
aggressive image it needs to strike back
it needs a little success it's it's lost
strings of agents in several European
countries in the last few years and
looked looked like it's losing the spy
game and this would be a way of showing
the world and itself and its own
operatives that hey you know we can take
the CIA run a high-level guy in there
and bringing back in a few months time
and make them look bad for a change if
you look at the Fuhrer and stir this
caused and the embarrassment to the CIA
it was a very successful operation if it
was planned by the Soviet Union all
along strange it's a very strange world
you're talking about don't ever forget
that thing we talked about last time of
the CI station chief in Saigon
delivering our most sensitive
information to the Communists throughout
the end for several years force for some
period of time yeah it's a very strange
world indeed